وبما أن المزيد والمزيد من الناس يتلقون
التطعيم ولا يزال هناك ارتباك
حول ما يمكنك وما لا يمكنك فعله
بعد ذلك ،
يجب أن يظل الناس يرتدون كتلة نعم
ويجب أن
يظلوا على علم بالعزلة والمسافة الاجتماعية إذا
تعرضوا لشخص معروف
لديك الفيروس في
الحجر الصحي بالتأكيد إذا تعرضوا
لشخص ما ليس مصابًا بالفيروس
جيدًا ، في الواقع ، ليس بالضرورة
أنك قلت شيئًا صحيحًا
وآخر ما سأعرفه فقط أعط تصحيحًا طفيفًا
للحقيقة هو أنه بعد ذلك  لقد تم
تطعيمك ، فمن
المحتمل أن تصاب بالعدوى ،
ولكن نظرًا لأنك تلقيت اللقاح ،
فلن تظهر عليك أي أعراض ، لذا فإن
الخبر السار هو أنك لا تعاني من أي أعراض
ولكن لا يزال من الممكن أن
تصاب بالفيروس.  البلعوم الأنفي الخاص بك
مما يعني أنه على الرغم من أنك
قمت بالتطعيم تشعر أنك على ما يرام ،
فمن الممكن أن تنشره إلى
شخص آخر ، وهذا هو السبب
الرئيسي لارتداء القناع على الرغم من أنك قد تلقيت
اللقاح
ولكن قرص مكافحة التصادم قد وصل إليك  وقلت الآن إذا
كنت قد تلقيت لقاحًا كاملاً
وتعرضت لشخص
معروف في الواقع أنه مصاب بـ covet 19 ، فأنت لست
بحاجة حقًا
إلى العزل والحجر الصحي بالطريقة التي
فعلت بها من قبل ، وهذا تغيير كبير
ولكن يجب عليك ارتداء قناع  لأنك في
الواقع
قد لا يزال بإمكانك التقاطه من شخص
ما فقط ونشره ، فلن
تمرض ، فلن تظهر عليك أعراض
بالضبط لأن اللقاح فعال بنسبة 94 إلى 95
بالمائة
في منعك من الإصابة
بمرض واضح سريريًا ولكننا  لا أعرف حتى الآن سنعرف
في وقت ما حيث نجري بعض
دراسات المتابعة لا نعرف حتى الآن
ما إذا كان بإمكانك أن تصاب بالعدوى وما
زلت قادرًا على نقلها
إلى شخص آخر ومن هنا جاءت
التوصية بارتداء القناع على الرغم من أنك '  لقد
تم تطعيمهم